.
"THE FIVE."
>> THE WHITE HOUSE NOT DENYING
REPORT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN SECRETLY FLYING
THOUSANDS OF UNCOMPANIED MIGRANT
CHILDREN FROM TEXAS TO THE NEW
YORK CITY AREA.
THE "NEW YORK POST" IS CALLING
IT BIDEN'S SECRET FLIGHT.
CLEVER.
IT IS REPORTING 2000 CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN FLOWN FROM SOUTHERN
BORDER AND SENT TO DROP-OFF
POINTS IN NEW JERSEY, AND
CONNECTICUT.
GOOD STORY FOR PETER DOOCY TO
ASK THE WHITE HOUSE IS.
>> Pete: WHY IS THE
ADMINISTRATION FLYING MIGRANTS
FROM THE BORDER TO FLORIDA AND
NEW YORK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT?
>> WELL, I'M NOT SURE IT IS THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, WHAT IS
HAPPENING --
>> DWO TIM
2:30 IN THE
MORNING.
>> EARLIER THAN YOU MIGHT LIKE
TO TAKE A FLIGHT.
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN PASSED
THROUGH THE AIRPORT EN ROUTE TO
FINAL DESTINATION TO BE UNIFIED
WITH THEIR PARENTS OR VETTED
SPONSOR.
>> TED CRUZ HAS IDEA WHY TO PUT
THE MASSIVE INFLUX OF MIGRANTS.
>> ENTIRE POLITICAL STRATEGY
SEBASED ON SECRECY, WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
IS  TRAGEDY.
STOP THE SURGE ACT, RICH
DEMOCRATS CAN BE SITTING THERE
AND SEE 10, 20, 30, 50,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTSS LIKE WE'RE
SEE OG A DAILY BASIS AND
ENVISION THEM IN NANTUCKET,
GOODNESS, THEY WANT TO COME TO
OUR CLUBS.
THEY WOULD BE HORRIFIED.
>> Greg: DANA, THAT WAS FROM
AMERICA'S NEWSROOM.
>> Dana: GREAT JOB.
>> Greg: SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING WE
COOKED UP, WHICH MEANS IT IS
GOOD.
PORT OF ENTRY, MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, IT IS VERY CLEVER, IT
MADE THE NEWS.
IT IS LEGITIMATELY CORRECT.
>> Dana: YES, HE MADE THE POINT
THIS MORNING AND WE'VE BEEN
SAYING THIS, TOO, PRESIDENT
BIDEN NEVER GONE TO THE BORDER.
KAMALA HARRIS, IN CHARGE OF THE
BORDER, DOESN'T GO.
SAY THERE IS A SDAF
NATURAL
DISASTER, WHAT DOES THE
PRESIDENT DO?
GOES DOWN AND VIEWS THE DAMAGE.
OKAY, WE NEED EMERGENCY
DECLARATION, THIS IS WHAT THEY
NEED AND YOU MAKE SURE THEY GET
EVERYTHING THEY NEED.
THEY IGNORE THIS.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAD TAKEN ALL THE GRIEF
FOR ALL THE THINGS ON
IMMIGRATION.
ALL PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD TO DO
WAS MAINTAIN STATUS QUO.
INSTEAD THEY DID A TWITTER POLL
AND MADE POLICY BASED ON THAT,
WHAT YOU END UP HAVING, POISONED
THE WELL AGAINST THE NEED AND
DEMAND FOR LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
PEOPLE HERE WAIT NOTHING LINE
TRYING TO GET IT DONE LEGALLY,
IT MADE THE ISSUE TOXIC.
THE OTHER THING, BECAUSE OF THE
FLORES AGREEMENT, THE CHILDREN
CANNOT BE HELD FOR LONGER THAN
30 DAYSS.
CUSTOM AND BORDER PATROL HAVE TO
SEND THEM SOMEWHERE.
THEY GIVE THEM TO HEALTH AND
HUSERVICES.
TALKING ABOUT PETE BUTTIGIEG.
WHERE IS THE SECRETARY.
IS HE IN WITNESS PROTECTION
PROGRAM?
>> Greg: THEY ARE ALL MISSING ON
MILK CARTONS.
HAROL
HAROLD, WHY DON'T DEMOCRATS TAKE
CRUZ AT HIS SUGGESTION, SHARE
THE RESPONSIBILITY, THAT WOULD
MAKE A LOT OF PEOPLE HAPPY,
REPUBLICANS HAPPY IF IT LOOKED
LIKE THE NON -- WHAT DO YOU CALL
NON-BORDER PRIVILEGED SHARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> YOU HAVE TO PUT PEOPLE ON THE
PLANE TO TAKE THEM, WE WOULD
HAVE THE ISSUE WE HAD WITH THIS,
IT WENT TO WESTCHESTER, PEOPLE
IN AND AROUND THE COMMUNITIES
AND GREENWICH PROBABLY NOT WANT
WHAT TED CRUZ IS TRYING TO
SUGGEST.
CAN YOU IMAGINE 30 YEARS AGO,
SENATOR JOKING LIKE SENATOR CRUZ
DID THERE.
HE IS A WELL EDUCATED GUY.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM AT THE BORDER,
IF YOU WANT TO SHAME DEMOCRATS,
SHAME THEM WITH POLICY.
I LAID OUT A PREDICATE, I HATE
TO SAY ON DAY WHEN SECRETARY
MAYORKIS, MY PRAYERS ARE WITH
HIM AND HIS FAMILY, HE IS
DEALING WITH COVID-19 POSITIVE
TEST.  WE HAVE TO GET A SERIOUS
PERSON THERE TO MANAGE THE
CRISIS AND WILLING TO NEGOTIATE
WITH REPUBLICANS.
AS MUCH AS THIS MAY GET
HEADLINES SENATOR CRUZ, WOO GET
A CHUCKLE, YOU STILL HAVE TO FLY
PEOPLE TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND
THE HAMPTON.
THE LARGER POINT, WE HAVE TO
INCENTIVIZE DEMOCRATS TO WANT TO
BE MORE SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
>> Dana: HE WENT TO SAY HE
KNOWSS THE DEMOCRATS WILL NOT
MOVE IT FORWARD, HE IS MAKING A
POINT.
THAT IS WHY YOU DO STUFF LIKE
THIS.
>> Greg: EXACTLY, KATIE, WHY DO
YOU THINK THE FLIGHTS WERE AT
NIGHT?
THEY ARE NOT HIDING FROM CNN,
THEY ARE NOT COVERING IT.
THEY DID THE FLIGHTS BECAUSE OF
FOX, THAT IS MY THEORY.
>> Dana: MAYBE THEY GOT THE IDEA
FROM YOU, GREG, YOU ARE SO
BRILLIANT.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
STOP.
>> Katie: SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND I CAN'T REMEMBER WHICH
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR OFFERED UP
JAY JOHNSON, UNDER OBAMA COME
MANAGE THE BORDER CRISIS BECAUSE
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS NOT DOING
THAT AND DEMOCRATS DIDN'T TAKE
HIM UP ON THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING, THEY ARE FLYING
PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT HOPING PEOPLE DON'T
NOTICE.
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER IS
SUBSIDIZING HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WHAT HAPPENS, IN SOUTH AMERICA,
SAY YOU ARE FROM EL SALVADOR,
SOMEBODY PAYS FOR UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR TO GET TAKEN TO THE BORDER
HHS GETS THEM AND THEY ARE FLOWN
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
I'M NOT SURE IF WE CAN FLY THEM
FROM THE BORDER TO NEW YORK WHY
NOT FROM THE BORDER TO EL
SALVADOR OR BACK TO WHERE THEY
CAME FROM TO REUNITE THEM WITH
THEIR FAMILIESS THERE.
APPARENTLY THAT IS NOT ON THE
TABLE.
LAWMAKERS HAVE BEEN SOUNGDING
THE ALARM FOR MONTHS.
FLYING TO TENNESSEE AND SENATOR
BLACKBURN SAID, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING, YOU ARE PUTTING FLIGHTS
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
THEY LIED ABOUT IT, THEY ARE
CAUGHT AND TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH IF IT IS THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT OR 4 IN THE MORNING.
>> Greg: JESSE, ANYTHING I'M
DOING AT 4 IN THE MORNING IS NOT
GOOD.
>> Jesse: THAT IS MY POINT,
ANYBODY THAT DOES SOMETHING IN
SECRET, THEY ARE NOT PROUD OF
THAT.
NO ONE IS PROUD OF WHAT YOU ARE
DOING IN SECRET IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT.
JOE KNOWS HE'S WRONG.
HE FEELS GUILTY ABOUT IT, THAT
IS WHY HE'S HIDING THIS LIKE A
COWARD.
OWN IT.
MAKE YOUR CASE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
DOING, THIS IS THE POLICY.
WE'LL DO IT IN DAYLIGHT.
HE CAN'T, HE KNOWS IF PEOPLE
KNOW ABOUT THIS POLICY, THE
COUNTRY WILL BE APPALLED AND NO
ONE BESIDES FOX WILL REPORT
THIS.
IF YOU ASKED JEN PSAKI ABOUT
THIS AND SHE DOESN'T GIVE YOU
ANSWER, FOLLOW-UP QUESTIONS.
YOU CAN'T VET SPONSORS AND
RELATIVES AFTER WHAT YOU DID IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WE DIDN'T EVEN GET OUR GUYS OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN, WE COULDN'T VET
AN ARMY AND YOU KNOW THE
SPONSORS ARE VETTED.
YOU KNOW THESE ARE THE REAL
PARENTS?
COME ON, YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
THIS IS TAXPAYER FUNDED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE THEY ARE
GIVING THEM TO?
WHO ARE THE AGENCIES RECEIVING
THE TEENAGERS?
WHO ARE THEY?
SHE CAN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION
AND SHE NEEDS TO BE ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
AMERICANS CAN'T EVEN GET ON
FLIGHTS BECAUSE THEY ARE BEING
CANCELLED BECAUSE OF VACCINE
MANDATES.
GIVE ILLEGALS, FREE FLIGHTS,
FREE FOODS.
HE'S ADVERTISING, CROSS OUR
BORDER IF YOU ARE UNDER 18,
WE'LL FLY YOU TO MIAMI OR NEW
YORK.
THIS IS CRAZY.
I DON'T THINK THINGS ARE RIGHT
UP THERE.
IT IS WRONG.
>> Greg: WEIRD THE TIMING, WHY
DOES IT HAVE TO BE AT 4 A.M.?
>> Jesse: WHY DO YOU THINK?
NOT EVEN TELLING THE GOVERNORS
HE'S DOING IT.
DOESN'T WANT ANYBODY TO KNOW.
>> Katie: PEOPLE IN THE AIRPORT
ARE WEARING THE SAME THING, THEY
HAVE PAPERWORK AND HAVE A
HANDLER.
IT IS ORGANIZED AND SOMEONE IS
GETTING PAID.
>> LET'S NOT SPECULATE TOO MUCH,
THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO DO THIS.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT